okay so there is a new tick tock trend
that people are calling out uh i forgot
what exactly was called but the gist of
it is that you kind of
devious licks thank you uh where a bunch
of students are just doing devious
things it started out with uh a picture
of kids basically tearing down a
restroom in a school they tear down the
stalls the st the sink out of the wall
and it's actually graduated to the point
where people are now slapping teachers
no [ __ ] way yeah if my kid slapped a
teacher oh my god slapping teachers and
there's videos of them slapping teachers
uh yes there is but the platform is
actually taking it down they're trying
to erase that whole hashtag so people
can't like tick tock should stop all
this [ __ ] so kids you know because
obviously they just want likes and views
and clicks so if you take that down
they're not gonna do it that's right
what are you doing tick tock
so the connecticut attorney general
actually came out with a statement
saying that tik tok is failing to spread
stop the spread of this dangerous
content because it's escalating you were
just trying to do bigger and bigger
stuff by china yeah i believe so yes
suspect
but how do they not just flag this off
the bat like all right we can't have
this dude slapping a t you imagine
slapping your teacher as a kid i was so
terrified my teachers i've seen my
teacher in a [ __ ] at the grocery
store and it was like your life would be
over yeah but oh my god tense up even
though i didn't do anything your life
would be over was it weird when you saw
your teacher at the grocery store like
holy [ __ ] they do something besides
teach and they're out
side clothes like they don't eat food
yeah i had a kid nine-year-old tell me
to [ __ ] off hell yeah just [ __ ] off yeah
yeah i was like is this court taking
cause you're just throwing a ball into
that dog i want to play tennis i love
that yeah we're playing here [ __ ] off
i love that kid and i went whoa whoa
whoa young man that's all i could do his
mom was like jeremiah i was like [ __ ]
off jesus christ man
full throated [ __ ] off
yeah it's not the first time you said it
hurt my feelings yeah that would hurt
you actually hurt my feelings what are
you going to do
yeah also like [ __ ] this these are just
keep them busy though and it was a big
nine-year-old i keep
getting busy yeah the nine-year-old
let's go bro hey what's going on
say it to my face he's like i said i'll
do to you what shop does to me when we
wrestle
yo you don't know he is